[Music]
on this launch pad in cape canaveral
florida nasa and boeing are counting
down to a high stakes
test flight of boeing's new starliner
spaceship now nobody's going to be in
this capsule for today's flight but
boeing needs to prove
that the starliner can fly safely to and
from the international space station
before astronauts are cleared for future
trips mark straussman is at the kennedy
space center with more on this story hey
mark good morning to you
hey gail good morning to you a boeing
starliner flies autonomously but as you
recall 18 months ago
software issues derailed the first test
flight so today's
launch is essentially the company's
expensive do-over
and its main customer is nasa and nasa
will be watching closely
three two one
and liftoff space is hard
so hard it can make even the biggest
aerospace company
in the world feels small vehicles now
passing through max q maximum dynamic
pressure
for boeing that was december 2019.
and we have good indication of
separation of the ofp capsule
minutes after separating from the
rocket's second stage
boeing's starliner flew into trouble its
onboard engines were supposed to fire
boosting the spacecraft into orbit that
did not happen
and we do have an off nominal insertion
reported
another problem flight controllers could
not communicate with starliner
by the time they could it was too late
without enough fuel left to reach the
international space station
starliner returned to earth and
starliner touches down in the desert
in new mexico a nasa boeing
investigation recommended
80 actions before starliner should fly
again
we addressed every single one former
nasa astronaut chris ferguson has spent
the last decade developing boeing
starliner
was it humbling i think humbling is a
good word to use
it was a good cause at least for
everyone involved in this program take a
step back and
look and see where we we came up short
and we needed to
sort of bolster and and i think you know
company-wide that
there was a lot there was a lot of
introspection in 2014
nasa awarded spacex and boeing
multi-billion dollar contracts
to ferry its astronauts to and from the
iss
both companies suffered setbacks and
look at them go
but spacex has flown 10 astronauts over
three flights to the iss
in the last year do you still believe
that having
a second option is necessary absolutely
bill nelson is nasa's administrator what
if we had only selected boeing
we would still be on the ground we would
still be
relying on the russians i think the
proof's in the pudding
nobody will follow this flight more
closely than the people training to fly
on starliner's first crude flight
like veteran nasa astronaut mike fink
from what we can see
and all the testing that we've done on
the ground we think it should go
well boeing has put a lot of effort and
a lot of their heart
into this spacecraft and we're looking
forward to watching it and
enjoying it with them the new and
improved starliner
rolled out of boeing's factory and off
to the launch pad
the capsule was hoisted on top of its
atlas v
rocket ready for today's launch boeing's
chance
to redeem its space reputation is there
a fair amount of pressure on this
for the company to nail this one there
is a
a perceptible need uh to go out and be
highly successful
and i think some of the pressure
self-induced and and i think from a
company level right they want to see us
be very successful as well
boeing will spend 400 million dollars
repeating this test flight
if today's launch is a go starliner will
dock to the iss
tomorrow spend a couple of days there
then come back to earth on monday
and if all goes well boeing could begin
flying people
by the end of this year anthony a lot
riding on this rocket
for boeing 400 million that's a lot of
money mark thank you